wie viel verdienst du mit Social Media
ist es komisch für deinen Freund dass
der Hof finanziell Dir gehört ich weiß
und es tut mir wahnsinnig leid dass ich
euch da ganz schön habe hängen lassen
die nächste Frage ist richtig peinlich
ihr habt mir mal wieder richtig
spannende Fragen zuugeschickt also
starten wir gleich rein in das Q&A mit
der ersten Frage fühlst du dich manchmal
von der Gartenarbeit überfordert oder
hast einfach keine Lust mehr aufs
Gärtnern aus reinem Herzen würde ich
jetzt sagen niemals aber der einzige
Grund dafür ist dass ich dieses Jahr
keinen Gemüsegarten habe weil wir
umgezogen sind mitten im Sommer das
heißt ich habe einfach eine enorme
gartensehnsucht in mir und romantisiere
das ganze komplett weil ich so vermisse
zu gärtnern ich freue mich so auf den
Frühling wenn mein Garten hier endlich
fertig ist aber ich weiß dass
realistisch gesehen ich in den letzten
Jahren immer wieder Punkte hatte gerade
so Richtung Spätsommer vor allem wenn
ich viel unterwegs war und ganz viel
reif wird dass mich das wahnsinnig
stresst dass ich nicht hinterherkme dass
Sachen schlecht werden im bet ich weiß
dass ich das eigentlich jedes Jahr hatte
indem ich gegärten habe diese Momente
wenn man das Gefühl hat man kommt nicht
hinterher bei mir ist das oft kombiniert
mit Urlaub und so weiter im Sommer also
ja ich kenne das auf jeden Fall und
trotzdem ist es für mich gerade komplett
unvorstellbar weil ich so viel
gartensehnsucht in mir habe dass ich ger
dann einfach nur toll finde was war die
schwierigste Entscheidung in deinem
Leben ich habe da lange drüber
nachgedacht über die Frage
übrigens die Fragen sind alle von
Instagram und ich finde ihr habt mal
wieder richtig gute Fragen gestellt
diesmal ich würde sagen die schwierigste
Entscheidung in meinem Leben war mich
von dem Papa von meinem Sohn zu trennen
nicht weil ich irgendwelche Zweifel an
der Entscheidung selbst hatte sondern
weil es so schwierig ist das war die
richtige Entscheidung und das wusste ich
auch aber es ist super schwer das dann
zu machen und zu wissen man macht da
irgendwie zu einem Teil seine Familie
kaputt ich hatte auch super doll Angst
davor alleine zu sein ich wusste nicht
was das richtige für mein Kind zu tun
das mir super schwer gefallen ich habe
da auch ganz lange drüber nachgedacht
und letztendlich ist alles gut so wie es
gewesen ist aber ist mir wahnsinnig
schwer gefallen wie bearbeite ich am
besten den Boden von einem neu
angelegten Beet in Klammern vorher Rasen
ich gärtnere ohne Umgraben das heißt ich
bearbeite den Boden überhaupt nicht ich
leg das Bed einfach direkt auf dem Rasen
an ich habe dazu auch einen Minikurs
gefilmt der heißt das Gemüsegarten
Bootcamp da starten wir vom Plan und
bete anlegen und dann gebe ich euch
Tipps zum Gärtnern mit an die Hand das
kostet euch 0 € das ist was was ich für
meinen Newsletter jedes Jahr neu Filme
und das könnt ihr euch gerne anschauen
der Link ist hier oben und im obersten
angepinnten Kommentar da findet ihr die
komplette Anleitung und da kann man ein
Beet innerhalb von einem Tag anlegen und
sofort losgärtnen und zwar ohne Umgraben
weil das nämlich für den Boden viel
besser ist und weil das ganz viele
Vorteile mit sich bringt z.B wächst da
kaum noch Unkraut und man muss viel
weniger gießen und das sind ja zwei
super nervige Aufgaben im Gemüsegarten
also ja kann ich absolut nur empfehlen
Flen die bete komplett ohne Umgraben
anzulegen habt ihr eure Hündin aus dem
Tierschutz i komm mal her das ist i guck
mal da an die
Kamera ja darf's wieder gehen denkt sich
auch was will die alte
ell ist ein Jagdhund weil mein Freund
firstster ist also die ist ein
Gebrauchshund und deswegen haben wir die
von einem Züchter der Jagdhunde züchtet
und die Rasse gibt der auch nur an Jäger
ab also das ist sozusagen ein kleines
Arbeitstier und deswegen haben wir die
nicht aus dem Tierschutz aber ich bin
absolut dafür dass wenn man sich einen
normalen Hund holt dass man den im
Tierschutz holt weil es gibt so viele
Hunde die da auf ein neues zuuh Hause
warten nur bei Gebrauchshunden ist das
halt nicht so einfach wie mit normalen
Hunden die nächste Frage ist richtig
peinlich was wurde eigentlich aus der
hunderttage Selbstversorger Challenge
ich weiß und es tut mir wahnsinnig leid
dass ich euch da ganz schön hab hängen
lassen weil ich diese Challenge gemacht
habe und ich habe auch immer kurzvos
gemacht um das zu zu begleiten aber nie
in ein langes Youtube Video ich glaube
die die das ganze nur auf tiktok und so
weiter verfolgt haben wissen wie es
ausgegangen ist aber ich habe das nie
hier auf Youtube mal in so einem langen
Video zusammengefasst und das liegt
daran dass wir ein großes Problem hatten
also erstmal hatte ich 100 bis 200
Stunden ungefähr Rohmaterial weil ich ja
jeden Tag sehr viel gefilmt habe während
ich die Challenge gemacht habe also vom
Pilz Sammeln von den Herausforderungen
von den schwierigen Momenten und den ers
schönen Momenten und dem ganzen Essen
das war super viel Material dann habe
ich mich dran gesetzt und das
geschnitten weil ich auch das Gefühl
hatte ich kann das nicht abgeben das
Schneiden weil das so intime Momente
waren beim Filmen denke ich mir ja schon
ganz viel über den Schnitt und ich hatte
irgendwie das Gefühl ich kann das nicht
an jemand anders so transportieren dass
ich am Ende ein Video hab was so ist wie
ich es will auch wenn ich andere Videos
wie dieses hier z.B nicht selber
Schneide aber es war einfach irgendwie
zu persönlich das Ding ist nur ich habe
echt nicht viel Zeit und erstmal so 100
bis 200 Stunden Rohmaterial zu sichten
zu schneiden das das ist extrem viel
Arbeit dann hatte ich die erste
Rohfassung die war 45 Minuten lang und
dann ist die gecrasht zwischendurch war
ich dann an dem Punkt dass ich gedacht
habe okay ich ich glaube das ganze
Projekt in die Tonne es wird dieses
Video nicht geben weil ich setze mich
nicht noch mal dran es geht nicht und
dann habe ich mich irgendwann ich glaube
es war im Frühsommer doch noch mal dran
gesetzt und wochenlang dran geschnitten
jetzt habe ich wieder eine rohvsion von
ich glaube 35 Minuten aber die ist immer
noch nicht so dass man die irgendwem
zeigen könnte es wird auf jeden Fall
kommen das Video es wird kommen ich
verspreche es euch und wenn esind zi
Jahren ist aber ich will euch zeigen wie
das war weil das waren 100 sehr krasse
Tage und das war eine Erfahrung die
werde ich nicht vergessen wie hältst du
deine bete schädlingsfrei erstmal würde
ich sagen dass ein schädlingsfreier
Garten ein ziemlich komischer Garten
wäre also das wä ziemlich unnatürlich
wenn da gar keine schellklänge vorkommen
würden aber ich glaube so ist die Frage
auch gar nicht gemeint und es gibt ja
ganz unterschiedliche Schädlinge aber
ich gehe jetzt mal so auf die häufigsten
ein ein ziemlich fieser Schädling ist
der coolweißling das ist dieser weiße
Schmetterling den kennt ihr bestimmt der
flattert rum und legt seine Eier vor
allem auf Kohlgewächse und da schlipfen
dann Raupen raus und die fressen alles
ab ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht dass
ich in meinem Garten ohne einen Schutz
gegen diese Raupen keinen Kohl anbauen
kann der da bleibt einfach nichts übrig
und deswegen decke ich die kohlbeete
immer mit einem kulturschutznetz ab es
ist ein ganz engmaschiges Netz das Regen
und Luft durchlässt aber eben die
Schmetterlinge nicht an die Pflanzen was
ja auch richtig fies ist sind Schnecken
die können ja auch alles abfressen
innerhalb kürzester Zeit und da habe ich
eine gute Erfahrung gemt wenn man zwei
Methoden kombiniert einmal abends mit
der Taschenlampe rumlaufen und die
absammeln und dann die Pflanzen die
wirklich gefährdet sind mit einem
schneckenring schützen also es sind so
Schneckenkragen die gibt's aus Plastik
und aus all aber es gibt auch so richtig
wabbelige aus Plastik nimmt wirklich
welche die mehrere Saisons halten weil
sonst finde ich das immer so eine
müllverschwendung und die stückt man
einfach so über die Pflanze drüber und
drückt die in die Erde und das ist dann
wie so ein Zaun dass die Schnecken da
nicht drüber kommen man muss nur
aufpassen dass nicht noch ein Grashalm
oder ein Blatt sozusagen eine Brücke
bildet über die die Schnecke dann
trotzdem über den Ring kommen kann weil
sonst hilft das natürlich nicht so habe
ich eigentlich gar keine
schneckenprobleme also einmal absammeln
und wegbringen die necken ich mache die
nicht tot ich finde das zu fies ich
bringe die einfach nur ganz weit weg
dann die einzelnen pflanzenschützen vor
allem die jungenpflänzchen von Kohl und
Salat alles was die Schnecken halt gerne
mögen sobald die Pflanzen groß sind oder
so im Teenageralter kann man die
Schneckenkragen dann auch abnehmen und
dann gibt's noch stechsaugende Insekten
wie z.B Blattläuse und da habe ich super
Erfahrung mit Niemöl gemacht ich sag mal
Niemöl oder Niemöl ich sag immer so eine
Mischung so dass man es nicht so genau
weiß aber das hilft gegen alle möglichen
stechsaugenden Insekten es ist gut immer
ein bisschen was davon dazu haben egal
wie man es jetzt ausspricht wie geht's
mit dem neuen Hof voran die Frage kam
auch ganz oft auch die Frage die nächste
passt auch dazu wann kommen endlich neue
Videos zum Hof die Sache warum auch
gerade nicht so viel Updates zum Hof
kommen ist dass ich einfach bisher kaum
da war also wir wohnen jetzt drei Monate
hier aber davon war ich ungefähr die
Hälfte der Zeit unterwegs weil ich auf
den vide dayss war auf dem Youtube
Festival auf dem Battle of the Socials
ich war in der Schweiz und in
Deutschland haben wir verschiedene
kurstenehmer von mir besucht und deren
Gärten angeschaut das war richtig toll
ich war in England wir hatten noch einen
Urlaub zwei Wochen einfach alles hat
sich so gebündelt in dieser Anfangszeit
vom Hof das äh habe ich irgendwie bereut
dass ich meinen Terminkalender da so
voll geballert habe weil das ja
eigentlich die Zeit ist auf die ich mich
so lange freut habe also eigentlich
seitdem ich ein Kind bin deswegen es es
immer noch so dass wir nicht alle
Umzugskartons ausgepackt haben ja wir
haben die Wände gestrichen ja wir haben
den Fußboden fertig aber sonst ist
einfach nichts passiert aber der Herbst
und Winter sind ruhiger da werde ich
nicht so viel unterwegs sein und dann
bekommt ihr auch bald wieder Vlogs und
so weiter und es wird viel mehr
passieren dazu fällt mir noch ein dass
ich immer wieder auch kurz Videos mache
also meistens schon jede Woche manchmal
auch mehrmals pro Woche wo ich euch so
kleine Updates gebe die lade ich immer
hier auf Youtube in den Shorts hoch also
da könnt ihr immer mal reinschauen um so
ein kleines Update zu bekommen was
gerade los ist und ganz bald kommen
wieder große wie und wo hast du deinen
Freund kennengelernt ist die nächste
Frage da muss ich euch erstmal ein
bisschen enttäuschen weil ich das nicht
erzählen werde aber ich kann so ein
bisschen darüber erzählen wie ich das
mit Beziehung und Beziehung teilen so
sehe ich habe einen starken
Beschützerinstinkt für meine Beziehung
nicht unbedingt für meinen Freund der
kann auf sich selber aufpassen aber ich
mag irgendwie das was zwischen uns ist
vor dem Internet beschützen ich merke
das auch jetzt gerade mit diesem Gossip
Skandal da ich musste Stories wo mein
Freund man nur seine Arme gesehen hat
löscht weil die Leute angefangen haben
ihn zu beleidigen ich weiß nicht was da
so der beste Umgang mit ist weil wir
merken auch jetzt wo wir auf dem Hof
auch zusammen an Projekten arbeiten ist
es mit dem Film super nervig dass ich
ihnen nicht zeige oder ich zeige Ihnen
wenn schon von hinten oder keine Ahnung
so dass man sein Gesicht nicht sieht ich
glaube er hätte jetzt auch nicht so ein
Problem damit zu zu sehen zu sein oder
ja dass man weiß wer er ist aber ich
habe das irgendwie ja deswegen halte ich
ihn irgendwie so ein bisschen raus aber
wir sind da auch nicht am Punkt bekmen
wo wir sagen das ist so unsere Lösung
sondern wir werden vielleicht auch
irgendwann andere Entscheidung treffen
auch weil es einfach nicht so
praktikabel ist i don't know im Moment
halte ich ihn daaus was mache ich mit
meinen kompostbeten im zweiten Jahr
kompostbete sind die bete die man ohne
Umgraben anlegt ich habe ja eben erzählt
vom Gemüsegarten Bootcamp im zweiten
Jahr muss man eigentlich gar nicht viel
machen man sollte so alle zwei bis drei
Jahre noch mal eine dünne Kompostschicht
ausbringen also nur so 2 bis 3 cm weil
sich durch die Regenwürmer und wenn man
so ein bisschen hakt in der Erde ja der
Mutterboden und der Kompost vermischen
und sonst wieder unkrautsaben nach oben
kommen können deswegen frischt eure BTE
immer mal zwischendurch so ein bisschen
auf man sieht das auch den Boden an wenn
der sich so sehr verändert dann ist es
wieder Zeit für eine dünne
Kompostschicht und ansonsten müsst ihr
da überhaupt nichts mehr machen immer
schön Molchen das ist wichtig und immer
alle paar Jahre mal ein bisschen Kompost
rausbringen die nächste Frage kam auch
sehr sehr oft und irgendwie freut mich
das weil ich die Idee total schön finde
nämlich was halten sie ihr müsst mich
nicht sizen ne was halten Sie von einem
Wurzelwerk Adventskalender das ist was
wo ich schon seit Jahren drüber
nachdenke weil ich Adventskalender liebe
ich liebe auch die Weihnachtszeit ich
liebe es mich darauf zu freuen ich würde
super gerne einen Adventskalender
rausbringen aber ich habe noch ein
bisschen Respekt davor wie viel Arbeit
das ist und ich habe auch so viele
Fragen also es gibt ja sehr viele
einfach reine Saatgut advventskalender
aber
irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie es euch
geht vielleicht reicht euch das ja auch
dann wä es easy dann könnte ich auf
jeden Fall einen rausbringen natürlich
nicht mehr dieses Jahr sondern nächstes
aber ich finde es schön wenn auch noch
irgendwie ein paar andere Sachen die so
im
selbstversorgerkosmos rumchweben mit
dabei wären vielleicht ein paar
pflanzschildchen vielleicht mal
ballprause zu Weihnachten oder so ja
auch mE ein richtig leckerer
weihnachtlicher Tee was haltet ihr davon
immer mal was Süßes aber nicht zu viel
ihr müsst mal sagen was ihr euch
wünschen würdet ich stell mir das auch
als
so schön vor wenn ich z.B jeden Tag
vielleicht erst abends damit ihr euch
nicht spoilern lasst in meiner Instagram
Story den Kalender auspacke und wir uns
dann alle irgendwie so als Gemeinschaft
fühlen können wir das alles so zusammen
erleben ja ich finde die Idee total
schön aber ich brauche ein Input das ist
auch eine richtig schöne Frage und ich
weiß dass ihr euch das total doll
wünscht wird ist das Saatgut das
Wurzelwerk Saatgut bald einzeln zu
kaufen geben wir haben ja bisher die
saatgutbox die kommt dreimal im Jahr mit
Samen die man dann auswähen kann als
kleine Erinnerungsfunktion
und so schön euch beim Auspacken
zuzugucken und das macht mir so Spaß die
zusammenzustellen und dann die kleine
Karte zu schreiben damit ihr wisst was
ich mir dabei gedacht habe und kleines
Geschenk auszusuchen was ihr dann
bekommt und ja das schon schon super
Projekt aber ich weiß ihr wünscht euch
einzelsat gut damit ihr viel besser
planen könnt damit ihr genau die Sorten
Einkaufen könnt die ihr wollt und wir
haben h wir arbeiten schon sehr lange
daran ein Sortiment
zusammenzustellen und es kommt Ende
November raus ich freue mich so euch das
zu erzählen das satgutprjekt ist
wirklich somit eins der schönsten
Projekte die ich bisher gemacht habe das
ist so unglaublich diese Tüten in der
Hand zu halten mit diesen wunderschönen
Illustrationen also Ende November geht's
los dann haben wir ein Sortiment wo ihr
euch die Tütchen einzeln rauspicken
wollt wenn ihr außerhalb der Box
einzelne Sorten bestellen wollt das wird
so cool ich frage mich ob wir irgendwann
so ein Katalog haben werden weil ich
finde es gibt nichts Schöneres als im
Januar auf dem Sofa zu sitzen mit einem
dampfenden Tee und satgutkataloge
durchzublättern und eine richtig große
Bestellung zusammenzustellen mit viel
mehr Sorten als überhaupt in den Garten
passen aber einfach ja weil man so viel
ausprobieren will das ist immer so eine
schöne Inspiration ich weiß nicht geht's
nur mir so wollt ihr ein Katalog oder
also jetzt im Frühling schaffen wir es
nicht aber wieder dann ein Jahr später
hättet ihr da Lust drauf oder ist es
oldscho und ich bin irgendwie so eine
kleine Ommi fühlst du dich manchmal
überfordert mit der ganzen Arbeit die
auf dem Hof auf euch wartet ehrlich
gesagt ärgert mich das mittlerweile so
ein bisschen dass gefühlt jeder sagt oh
das ist ja bestimmt so viel Arbeit auf
dem Hof und klar das ist nicht keine
Arbeit aber das ist einen Hof der sehr
gut instand ist und es gibt jetzt kein
Projekt wo ich sagen würde das müssen
wir jetzt wirklich dieses Jahr unbedingt
noch machen das das heißt wir ziehen
hier ein ist alles komplett bezugsfertig
klar das Bad ist nicht schön aber es ist
jetzt nicht so dass uns das so stört ich
glaube vielleicht sind da manche Leute
auch anders aber es gibt keine Stelle an
der es irgendwie so doll brennt dass man
jetzt unbedingt was machen muss also der
Hof ist für uns bisher kein Stressfaktor
gewesen was macht dein Plan wieder
Ziegen zu halten wann geht's los wir
haben in diesem Garten so viele
Obstbäume also wirklich der komplette
Rasen ist überall voll mit Obstbäumen es
gibt eigentlich kein Flecken außer da wo
das gebächshaus hinkommt wo noch Platz
wäre für Weidefläche und Ziegen haben ja
die Angewohnheit dass die eigentlich
Sträucher und Bäume viel lieber fressen
als Gras deswegen können wir hier im
Garten leider keine Ziegen halten weil
die sbäume auch alles Halbstämme sind
das heißt selbst wenn ich den Stamm
Schütze werden die auf die Hinterbeine
gehen und alle Obstbäume bis auf eine
Höhe von 2 m abfressen also ich hatte
sehr lange Ziegen seit ich 12 war und
seit einem Jahr habe ich keine mehr das
wird sich auch erstmal nicht n weil es
hier nicht möglich ist es gibt ja auch
so minikühe ne ich weiß der Garten ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu klein
aber diese Mini Highland kettle sind so
fast süß große Versuchung die geben auch
nicht so viel Milch aber wir brauchen
auch nicht so viel Milch muss nur für
für ein Kaffee reichen ich muss nicht
unbedingt Käse machen wenn die süß sind
ist ist schon okay ich habe wirklich
schon Züchter rausgesucht weil ich so
begeistert von denen bin ich glaube es
ist ein bisschen übertrieben was sagt
ihr was sind die anfängerfreundlichsten
Gemüsepflanzen ich würde einfach mal so
raushauen Zucchini Knoblauch Mangold die
wachsen ohne Probleme also da kann man
wirklich nichts falsch machen oder nur
sehr wenig Sachen Radieschen sind auch
schön weil die super schnell wachsen
weil Gärtnern ist ja so man wartet lange
darauf dass man irgendwann belohnt wird
gerade wenn man anfängt ist es glaube
ich sehr motivierend wenn man dann schon
mal die erste Sache erntet und ich sag's
euch das ist so ein Glücksgefühl wenn
man die erste eigene Ernte in den Händen
hält und weiß ich habe das aus Samen und
Erde gezogen deswegen werde ich euch die
ans Herz legen aber es gibt noch so viel
mehr Gemüse die meisten kriegt man auch
im ersten Jahr ohne viel Erfahrung hin
und es muss nicht alles immer perfekt
laufen ist es komisch für deinen Freund
dass der Hof finanziell Dir gehört ich
glaube ja das ist schon komisch für ihn
ist also wir können da zum Glück sehr
offen drüber reden ich habe den Hof
gefunden bevor ich meinen Freund
kennengelernt habe und wir sind
zusammeneng gekommen bevor ich ihn
gekauft habe also in dem Zeitraum
dazwischen haben wir uns kennengelernt
und sind zusammengekommen ich glaube es
ist auf verschiedenen Ebenen komisch
weil ich habe damit quasi schon gesetzt
wo ich wohne also wir waren auch in der
Fernbeziehung und es war dann für ihn
irgendwie klar auch wenn ich das
natürlich nicht erwartet habe aber das
wenn wir zusammen wohnen wollen dass es
nur hier sein kann viele Leute wollen
das ja dass sie ein Haus haben irgendwie
so auch als Sicherheit fürs Alter und so
weiter das dann abbezahlen und dann ja
einfach ein Haus haben also ja es ist
jetzt nicht super schlimm für ihn und
der wohnt hier gerne und fühlt sich
hoffentlich auch genauso zu Hause wie
ich also ich will ihm nicht das Gefühl
geben dass er hier zu Gast ist sondern
das ist genauso sein Haus wie mein nur
dass es mir auf dem Papier gehört du
würdest auf einer einsamen Insel
stranden und könntest nur fünf
Gemüsesorten mitnehmen welche wären es
da kann man ja zwei Ansätze irgendwie
erstmal so denken ne geht's um survival
dann Wste ich glaube ich dass ich auf
jeden Fall Kartoffel und Topinambur
mitnehmen würde Mais einen Ölkürbis und
Bohnen aber wenn es so um Genuss geht
dann Tomaten auf jeden Fall mein
Lieblingsgemüse sind so Erbsen frisch
vom Strauch so lecker und Spinat ich
muss ja Spinatlasagne machen ich würde
noch Pastinake mitnehmen und als fünftes
würde ich weißkol mitnehmen damit ich
Sauerkraut machen kann sauerkraut ist
auch sehr sehr lecker würdest du ein
Rezeptbuch zum Einkochen und
fermentieren rausbringen oder auch die
Frage ob ich noch mal ein Buch schreiben
will ich hatte letztens auch ein
Gespräch mit meinem Verlag wo ich das
Buch geschrieben habe und musste den
sagen nee mache ich nicht normal weil
ich liebe mein Buch wirklich also ich
bin stolz darauf ich finde es ist ein
sehr gut gutes Buch ich liebe das Cover
es hat mich sehr viel also es war schon
sehr sehr viel Aufwand das zu schreiben
und ich schreibe super gerne aber mein
Traum ist es Romane zu schreiben und
wenn ich irgendwann mal so viel Zeit
habe dass das wieder drin ist dann
möchte ich das machen und nicht jetzt
noch einen Sachbuch schreiben wo ich
sozusagen die gleiche Zeit aufwende aber
nicht meinen Traum verfolge und außerdem
habe ich schon quasi ein Buch über das
Einkochen und fermentieren geschrieben
weil ich ja einen Onlinekurs habe der
heißt UPS und Gemüse haltbar machen da
haben wir ganz viele Rezepte drin auch
richtig viele super leckere
Familienrezepte und genau also es gibt
das quasi schon aber das noch mal das
Buch rauszubringen ist für die Leute
doof die den Kurs schon haben und habe
ich auch nicht vor ne wenn ein Buch dann
ein Roman bei der nächsten Frage habe
ich lang drüber nachgedacht ob ich die
mit reinnehmen soll wie viel verdienst
du mit Social Media da muss ich erstmal
so ein bisschen ausholen weil wenn ich
im echten Leben Leute kennenlerne und
die irgendwann hören so das ist mein Job
Youtube Videos zu machen dann fragen die
immer so h wie kann man denn davon leben
wie funktioniert das einerseits bekommt
man halt über Youtube Werbeeinnahmen ich
bekomme jeden Monat je nachdem wie viele
Aufrufe ich hatte einen Betrag
überwiesen ich kann euch gerne sagen wie
viel das ist das schwankt halt sehr
stark allein schon weil meine Themen
sehr saisonal sind das heißt im März
habe ich viel mehr Aufrufe als im
September also die Shorts die gehen
durch die Decke manchmal habe ich keine
Ahnung 10 Millionen Shorts Aufrufe im
Monat das ist nicht sasonalbedingt weil
ich da eher so Vlogs mache aber dafür
kriegt man auch nicht wirklich Geld aber
für die langen Videos da schwankt es
halt sehr weil ihr halt im Frühling die
gartenvos guckt und nicht im Winter das
sind sagen wir so zwischen 3 und 10 000
€ im Monat die ich davon bekomme man
muss sagen ich habe ein Team von 14
Leuten die kann ich damit natürlich
nicht anlähend bezahlen also auch
Kameraequipment ist teuer allein das was
ich nur von Social Media bekomme von
Instagram bekomme ich z.B nichts keine
Werbeeinnahmen von tiktok habe ich mich
noch nicht angemeldet dafür sollte ich
mal machen also youtube ist die einzige
Plattform die mir sozusagen direkt
Werbeeinnahmen ausschüttet aber davon
könnte ich Wurzelwerk so wie wir das
gerade haben nicht stemmen weil da halt
noch so viel mehr dazu gehört der Rest
trägt sich halt selber also ich habe
zwei Onlinekurse Gemüsegarten starten
ist der zum Gärtnern Obst und Gemüse
haltbar machen ist der zum haltbar
machen der Ernte und damit verdienen wir
Geld so dass wir das Team bezahlen
können und euch unterstützen können in
den Kursgruppen und neue Inhalte für
euch erstellen können und wir arbeiten
gerade an noch einem dritten Kurs der
heißt Balkongarten starten dafür habe
ich auch neue Leute eingestellt das
heißt ich steck da gerade sehr viel Geld
rein ohne dass ich jetzt sofort was
davon habe also es dauert jetzt
anderthalb Jahre von dem Beginn des
Projekts bis wir den Kurs dann fertig
haben und verkaufen können das ist halt
ein großes Standbein was ich habe die
Onlinekurse das ist auch was wo ich
absolut für brenne was mir mega Spaß
macht weil es so schön ist diese
Transformation zu sehen vom Rasen zum
üppigen Gemüsegarten hoffentlich jetzt
bald vom leeren hässlichen Balkon zu
einem richtigen stadtdschungel das macht
wahnsinnig viel Spaß und wir haben eben
jetzt auch unser Saatgut rausgebracht
ein riesiger Meilenstein für mich
persönlich das ist gerade noch so mit
dem ganzen Onlineshop also wir verkaufen
auch Werkzeuge und die Schneckenkragen
die kulturschutznetze von denen ich euch
erzähle also all die Sachen die ich euch
sowieso immer empfohlen habe weil ich
die super finde kaufen wir ein und
verkaufen die im Shop das ist gerade
halt auch noch so ein riesen
anfangsinvestment weil ich dieses
riesige Lager füllen muss dann liegt
dann großer wenwert der sich natürlich
noch nicht abverkauft hat es ist jetzt
gerade zum ersten Mal so dass ich auch
bisschen mehr gucken muss finanziell was
für Entscheidung treffen wir in der
Firma aber ich kann sehr sehr gut davon
leben was ich mache weil als ich
angefangen habe mit meinem Blog damals
noch mit 18 bin ich schwanger geworden
da war ich noch in der Schule bin dann
ausgezogen in so eine
einzimmerkellerwohnung mit dem Papa von
meinem Sohn und wir haben halt aus den
Mülltonnen gegessen weil wir kein Geld
hatten uns essen zu kaufen also aus
Supermarkt Mülltonnen wir waren ganz
viel Containern und haben uns irgendwie
so über Wasser gehalten jetzt so gut zu
verdienen ist für mich ehrlich gesagt
auch irgendwie schwierig weil ich habe
lange gebraucht um zu akzeptieren dass
ich das verdient habe es ist so dass ich
jetzt einfach mich darüber freue dass
ich jetzt davon sehr gut leben kann es
ist trotzdem immer noch komisch aber ich
glaube weil ich halt so anders kenne
einfach nur ein riesengroßes Dankeschön
dass ihr mich und meine Projekte
unterstützt das ist wirklich nicht
selbstverständlich und wenn ihr
weiterschauen wollt dann findet ihr da
drüben mein letztes Q&A wo ich ganz
viele Fragen rund um den Hof beantwortet
habe und ansonsten geht raus macht die
Welt ein bisschen grüner und wir sehen
uns im nächsten Video wieder macht's gut
tschüss das nächste Video wird ein
hofvlog